joining us with reaction Fox News
national and security strategist
Sebastian Gorka Fox News contributor
Sarah Carter and Fox News legal analysts
Greg cherry on top of the Sid Vicious
Blumenthal things so we now have our FBI
Sarah Carter literally telling this is
new to me the the guy that's paying for
Russian lies Alicia's details on a
candidate to to basically fix an
election with phony Russian propaganda
they're giving him information I think
that's incredible you know you would
think that the FBI would be close hold
about their own investigation before
sharing that obviously with an ex
British spy who's working for fusion GPS
who's being paid by the DNC in the
Hillary Clinton campaign is Sean the FBI
usually does not share information with
people that they're interviewing and if
you if steal is delivering information
to the FBI it should be the FBI
questioning steal not steal questioning
the FBI well I think what's interesting
to me is after Steele got this
information where did still go with it I
mean this is a question that needs to be
answered
did Steele approach Papadopoulos did he
approach sources of Papadopoulos how
much information did he get from the FBI
on George papadopolis and those are
questions that still need to be answered
you did a great chair affirm the legal
side of this you see any legal issues
and you've been the one that was been
pointing out you have four levels deep a
hearsay yeah that would never be
accepted in any court you know this just
underscores the FBI was politically
motivated to damage Trump their meeting
with Steele they're trying to connect
the dots with Papadopoulos they're
offering to pay money to steel to
continue to dig dirt on Donald Trump
they became in a way just a political
arm of the Democratic National Committee
and the Trump campaign after the FBI
cleared for political reasons Hillary
Clinton in the email scandal and then
launched a political vendetta to frame
Trump over Russian collusion without a
scintilla of evidence all right
Sebastian let me get to you dr. Gorka so
she fixed the primary with Bernie
Sanders she had
legal issues so she could stay in the
game she had the FBI director and Peter
struck who hates Trump loves Hillary fix
it so she can keep working otherwise we
know felonies were committed mishandling
classified information etc then we
literally have that fake dossier you
know used to fix the general election
and then it's used for a FISA warrant
against the opposing candidate in an
election year and it's used to surveil
than a president-elect on his team Sean
I'm a legal immigrant to this country
I'm proud to be an American I am ashamed
and horrified by everything we are
learning every day from Sarah from a
colleague John from you from Greg Jeff
Flake should be concerned with the
Stalinist tactics of the Obama
administration not insulting this
president who lost its country what we
are seeing is the systematic targeting
of political adversaries using
trumped-up intelligence files full of
propaganda and using domestic
surveillance we have to use that phrase
Sean it is the domestic surveillance for
political purposes against people who
were running against them as their
political opponents that's what
communist authoritarian regimes do I
hear now we now know that the the the
DOJ had to release the documents that
the FBI had subpoenaed they did it
last-minute rod Rosenstein tried to
prevent it he goes in to Paul Ryan's
office begs him not to do it we're
getting some insight as to what we will
learn next week Sarah Carter what are
you hearing
well extensive FISA abuse what Sebastian
just brought up is very important I mean
we have to look at what type of
surveillance was being conducted
what warrant what did they have as far
as evidence to obtain warrants to
actually spy on members of file a
dossier was used and then the FBI's yes
collaborating with the guy that's
getting the phony brush and propaganda
you can't make this up no you can and I
think Byron York brought up some really
interesting facts
his column today the fact that steel
could have been doing separate reports
other reports other than the dossier for
memory suspect Department and they
suspect he was paid and he had a very
close relationship with members of the
State Department so this is something
that's being investigated you know when
you hire a spy who's trained in lies and
deception
who relies on Russian spies trained in
lies and deceptions you get nothing but
lies and deceptions that is the basis of
the dossier and for the FBI to believe
this document which on its face is
fictitious is an abuse of power because
it never with dentists they went to a
judge to get a warrant to spy you can't
that's a fraud on a court to use if I
want to hear from that judge that Judge
no judge I know likes being lied to
alright last so we have the fake news
Awards released tonight Sebastian Gorka
it's not only the purports they get
wrong it's also the stories they will
not cover these stories and I I just see
nothing but egg all over their face
coming I am so it's so magnanimous of
the president to put Russian collusion
at the bottom of the list
Russian collusion not Paul Krugman that
laughable individual that should be at
the top of the list and I'm glad you've
got a sense of humor because you have to
have a sense of humor 50 minutes on what
the president's belt sizes and whether
he has two scoops it's a parody of media
Shawn it's an absolute joke a list is
great we'll have more on it with
Michelle Malkin and joke